NICK ORLOVE: Hey, we're late
for the small data meetup.
Are you coming?
STEPHANIE WONG: I can't.
I'm waiting for this
BigQuery job to finish.
Can you wait 18.2 seconds?
NICK ORLOVE: But then
all the sparkling water's
going to be gone.
Come on.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Well, at that point,
is it even worth going then?
NICK ORLOVE: Well, I bet if
you use BigQuery's clustering
and partitioning
features, your queries
would run much
faster and cheaper.
STEPHANIE WONG: That'd be great.
Can you show me how?
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, let's do it.
See, BigQuery's a great tool for
analyzing huge amounts of data
quickly, but there
are plenty of times
where you only care to
analyze a subset of your data.
For example, you may
only want to look
at data over a
particular period of time
or over a particular column.
If you check out the
illustration on the screen,
you can see that I'm
converting my unordered table
on the left into a date
partition table on the right
and clustering my
tags closer together.
This is really going
to optimize my queries
when I analyze my data.
Now looking at my
GCB project, you
can see that I have
a Stack Overflow data
set, which contains a table
with 10.8 million Stack Overflow
questions which have
been gathered since 2014.
This was pulled from the
BigQuery Stack Overflow
public data set by the way,
which everyone has access to.
From the schema, you can
see that this table contains
a bunch of great information
from each Stack Overflow
question such as the ID,
title, body, creation date,
number of comments, what
it's been tagged with,
view count, et cetera.
That's a lot of data across
10.8 million Stack Overflow
questions.
So let's say you want to
gather some information
on the types of questions
being asked about Android
in the last six months.
To accomplish this, I wrote
this simple SQL query.
We can see that we only care
about dates in the last six
months and anything that
has a tag Android in it.
When running this query
against my standard table,
it has to scan all
of the data and all
of the tags and the
creation date column,
so you can see that
it takes a few seconds
and scans the full
18 gigabytes of data.
Now if we set up the
table to be partitioned,
BigQuery will only scan
the parts of the table that
fall into this date range.
Ideally, you should start using
partitioning when you first
create your table.
However, I'll run a DDL, or
Data Definition Language,
query to create a new table
from this existing table
and use the creation underscore
date column as my custom
partitioning column.
Now let's run that query
against my partition table.
You can see that it returns
in about a quarter of the time
and scans about a tenth
of the amount of data.
Impressive.
STEPHANIE WONG: So let
me get this straight.
BigQuery is taking care
of all of the hard work?
NICK ORLOVE: Yep.
You just tell it what date
field you want to partition by,
and BigQuery knows exactly
what partition ranges
to use to maximize efficiency.
STEPHANIE WONG:
But what if I want
to partition my data on
something like a text column?
NICK ORLOVE: That's where
clustering comes in.
Let me show you.
Looking at this
query, we're taking
advantage of partitioning
because we're
filtering by creation date.
However, the query still needs
a scan across all the tags
to find out which ones are
Android, even though we're only
looking for a single keyword.
Clustering is a way for
BigQuery to optimize
the placement of
your data and allows
it to store alike
data closer together
to make queries more efficient.
Typically clustering works best
on high cardinality fields,
which maximizes the amount
of benefit you'll get.
By the way, you can
cluster on multiple columns
so you aren't
limited to just one.
Just like partitioning,
you should set up
clustering at the get go.
So I'll run a similar DDL as
before to create a new table,
but this time we'll cluster
our data using the column tags.
So now if we run these
queries with clustering,
we can see that we get our
results slightly faster,
and we're now scanning megabytes
of data instead of gigabytes.
STEPHANIE WONG: So if I
use BigQuery's partitioning
and clustering, I'll
only scan the data
that I need to save
both time and money.
NICK ORLOVE: Exactly.
It takes a little bit
more work upfront,
but it's definitely worth it.
STEPHANIE WONG: And for those
of you watching at home,
check out the link
in the description
to try it out for yourselves.
Don't forget to like, comment,
and subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]